Netflix's newest fan favorite as a
heartbreaking 13 reasons why a teen
drama based on the 2007 Jay Asha novel
of the same name the series features a
ton of fresh-faced actors including one
you'll swear you seen before Dylan
Manette who stars as clay Jensen why is
he so familiar here are 13 reasons why
saving grace minute first made his mark
in 2007 as a series regular and his TNT
crime drama where he played another
character named clay the young and oh so
lovable clay Norman the nephew of the
strung out self-destructive detective
played by Holly Hunter Manette mature
performance earned him back sabaki young
artist Awards in 2008 and 2009 lost his
next big TV role was short-lived but
what a role it was in 2010 Manette
played David Shepherd the sort of son of
jack and Juliet on the controversial
final season of the time hopping ABC
adventure drama lost fans like you
remember Manette from the episode
lighthouse in which Jack sets david down
for a heart-to-heart I will always love
you no matter what you do in my eyes you
can never fail too bad Manette's
character only existed in a post death
metaphysical realm but that's just how
lost her old lets me in he is where
things get dark Manette entered the
horror see in that same year as a bully
named Kenny in his adaptation of the
2008 Swedish vampire flick led to the
right one n hey little girl
[Music]
his chilling portrayal of the preteen
tormentor earned him two more young
artists Award nominations for kids on a
roll
awake audiences definitely woke up when
they first saw Manette spinning through
the air in this short-lived 2010 MBC
police procedurals starring Jason Isaacs
awake followed an LAPD detective who's
torn between two different timelines
after a car accident launches him into
the supernatural Manette plays Britain's
son Rex
appearing only in what's known as the
green reality the world in which Rex
survives tragedy and his mother doesn't
apparently have a gift to playing teams
who may or may not really exist
prisoners in 2013 the then
seventeen-year-old Manette joined an
impressive ensemble and this thriller
centered around one father's primal
reaction to an unthinkable crime Manette
played Ralph Dover son of Hugh Jackman's
Keller who abducts and the torches of
man he suspects of kidnapped his
daughter with his fellow cast members
Manette won the National Board of Review
Award for Best ensemble Alexander and
the terrible horrible no good very bad
day Manette's next project was a leading
role in this 2014 family comedy Manette
played Alexander's older brother Anthony
an accident-prone team dealing with the
drama of an on-again off-again
relationship with his girlfriend while
also struggling to pass his driving test
I'll be your driving examiner
I don't think he passed oops for
checkout that clay Jensen asked for head
bandage how uncanny is that goosebumps
Manette jumped into the spooky world of
RL Stein in this 2015 comedy as Zack
Cooper the fictionalized Stein's
unassuming neighbor the film follows sac
as he settles into his new small-town
Maryland home after moving from the Big
Apple and accidentally brings Stein
scary stories to life maybe they're
friendly oh not friendly don't breathe
Manette's most recent appearance on the
silver screen it was in this
claustrophobic 2016 horror gem as Alex
one of the three friends who gets
trapped inside the house of a terrifying
character known as the blind man Alex
struggles to make a tell to life facing
multiple deadly obstacles on his way but
that's not all still don't know where
you see Manette how about this 2009
appearance of Stanley Carter in season 4
of Supernatural or as a teen accused of
murder on the supernatural drama medium
or maybe his 2012 appearance on Law &
Order SVU as a troubled teen entangled
in a sexual assault case what about his
role as the icy supervillain blizzard
and Marvel's agents of shield or maybe
you saw him get whacked on the
heart-stopping political drama scandal
where he played the president's doomed
son that be lucky 13 there you have it
13 reasons why clay from 13 reasons why
looks so darn familiar thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]